what's going on guys this is rob uh if
you guys enjoy my content make sure you
hit the subscribe button
and make sure you hit that little bell
so you never miss out on my sexy voice
okay so we are uploading this kind of
late um
because i just got back from disney
world uh had an amazing trip it was
awesome i'll probably have a video about
it on my vlogging channel uh but we are
covering the batman who laughs part
three and in the last video we basically
picked up with
essentially the return of james gordon
jr now james gordon jr
is the son of commissioner gordon of
james gordon and of course the brother
of barbara gordon batgirl but the cool
thing about james gordon jr is that he's
imagine the joker if he was
rational which i know kind of takes away
from the premise of like a psychopath
but when it comes to james gordon jr
he's one of these guys where all he did
was like think and plan ways to like
wipe out people destroy things cause as
much like you know
pandemonium and chaos as he possibly
could and so because that of course he
was basically in prison and of course he
was put in a program
where it was basically a drug that was
produced by wayne pharmaceuticals that
could essentially cure a person who was
a psychopath
and if i remember correctly from batman
eternal and from forever evil
the idea was to test the drug on james
gordon jr to see if it would work on
like the joker or somebody like that so
it was kind of a test subject more or
less but for the most part it's been
working
while he takes two shots a day like
tests his blood you know to make sure
that everything's still in effect and so
on and so forth he gets kind of nuts in
terms of how he how he lives his life
but it's super super strict to make sure
he doesn't go back to doing what he was
doing before but the idea behind this is
you know for those of you guys who are
catching up the idea behind this was
that the joker when he was taken
prisoner by batman are really kind of
brought in by batman and then so on
everything kind of unfolded
is that james gordon jr is the key to
stopping the batman who laughs and we
didn't really know how far this key
extended right like we didn't really
know what doors it unlocked but that's
essentially what this kind of does
when you have james gordon meeting with
his son it's really kind of scott snyder
giving us this refresher and saying
here's what james has been doing but
then of course the group is met with the
arrival of batman and this is when
things get kind of cool
because what bruce says on a normal
circumstance when bruce wayne approaches
someone like this he wants them for a
particular purpose but he wants to make
sure that things stay on the up and up
when he approaches james gordon jr what
he says is i don't want the version
that's doing what he's supposed to do
like i don't want the one who's a good
guy i want the murderer like i want the
murderer the killer
the crazy psychopath that's the version
that i want and the whole idea behind
this is as batman explains is that the
batman who laughs is implementing a plan
to essentially like destroy gotham now
we don't know exactly what this plan
is in its entirety we just know like the
batman who laughs wants to unleash
pandemonium and chaos and the way this
snyder plays this out is it looks like
it'll be something that's far more
extreme than like
batman end game for logic actually never
read batman in game what we ended up
finding out was the joker had this plan
to essentially release joker talks and
across the entire city of gotham and to
send the city into like
like mass hysteria and into like you
know chaos and and panic and so on and
so forth and it worked he actually did
it like it was it was kind of nuts the
way it all played out but of course with
batman using the
last laugh plan which was essentially
using like the tunnels of gotham to
essentially pump out like a cure to the
joker toxin we're all that's kind of
out the window now the idea is to know
what the joke what the batman who last
plan is going to be and because james
gordon jr is a legitimate
psychopath who spent a majority of his
life just like analyzing and trying to
find ways to destroy things
he's the best person to go to because
right now they can't really they can't
get answers from the joker and so it's
kind of cool because what this is is an
act of desperation while james gordon jr
is a psychopath he's not exactly like
the batman who laughs
the batman who laughs is a combination
of the joker and batman this is an
answer to the question
what would happen if batman became the
joker and so the best person to go to
is the joker but the joker's not
spilling the beans he's not giving any
real answer and the only answer he did
give is
go find james gordon jr he's the answer
you're looking for and so that's
literally why batman's following these
breadcrumbs and following these
directions is because he doesn't really
have a choice here it's kind of funny
because
james gordon jr does not want to do any
of this stuff james gordon jr is like i
don't want to do this like i do not want
to jump into this scenario again i don't
want to go back to being that version of
myself so he's very much against the
idea which really kind of ties batman's
hands and so when they try to reason
with him and they say like put down the
scanner and and like talk to us he says
like i'm not the one with this red dot
meaning
somebody's targeting them and that's
whenever when when like all hell starts
to break loose because of course the
group is met by the arrival of what's
basically punisher batman and this is
cool
because punisher batman and like batman
himself actually face off against each
other it's basically a guy who's
shooting to kill
versus a guy who's not and they're able
to like dodge the attacks of each other
so for the most part it's it's a
stalemate in so far as
one of them kind of gets the upper hand
you know batman kind of gets the upper
hand on punisher batman but not really
and the reason why
is because where punisher batman's kind
of caught unawares with like a grappling
hook and basically kind of left dangling
over
over a bridge and whatnot uh you end up
having him basically like bringing all
these different vehicles and so on and
then say like there's a jet flying above
us and if you do not give me james
gordon i'm going to destroy the jet i'm
going to destroy one of its one of its
uh one of its engines this is cool
because what this does is it again
hints at the idea and really kind of
points to the idea of how capable this
evil alternate reality version of batman
is that in his universe there are no
villains there's no joker no scarecrow
no penguin no two-face no nothing he's
killed them all that he has
basically uh gone through and like
essentially like controls the entire
city of gotham right even hits it like
you know hits home what he calls the
colony and so that's really kind of
scott snyder basically bringing in the
idea of like tom king and james tanian's
batman run
or batman detective comics run when you
have the colony right like this
organization that essentially uh kind of
took over kind of a paramilitary group
the father of batwoman who took over
wanted to take over gotham city and then
like basically weaponized batman's
technology to essentially control the
city of gotham and then alternate
reality this punisher batman's done that
and so being that capable he's basically
began
colonizing gotham city in like the main
dc universe by basically saying like i
know everything that's going on
everywhere at least you know i'm getting
to the point where i am
and so him basically saying like if you
don't do what i tell you to then i'm
going to take out this plane
72 people are going to die 41 of them
are gothamites i'm gonna kill them all
all you have to do is give me
commissioner gordon and it all goes away
and where where gordon is kind of like
where he believes that this is son that
he's talking about the response of
batman is it's not the sun
it's you and he literally knocks out
commissioner gordon and hands him over
to like punisher batman and the idea
behind this at least
you know in terms of why this is being
done is batman says that when it came to
like the whole last laugh device that he
had
the device that would serve the purpose
of like allowing a cure to be
implemented throughout the city of
gotham
required like a two-point activation it
required batman and someone he trusted
the only the only other person he really
trusts
being commissioner gordon now switching
over to the iceberg lounge to uh to to
penguin it's kind of cool here because
of course the batman who laughs
basically busts in
and starts torching the place literally
using the various weapons and
and gimmicks of the joker i'm sorry of a
penguin to start tearing everything up
and start letting everything and setting
everything on fire now some of the
gimmicks that really seem to be brought
here by batman who laughs
seem to be gimmicks from his own
universe which is to say like one of the
the i guess you know
an umbrella of the penguin that can
shoot alcohol which in turn if given a
flame can set everything on fire just
small little things like that that are
that are really interesting and really
really smart for him to use in this
scenario by literally taking out all the
forces of penguin and then bringing in
another version
of bruce wayne and in his alternate
reality version of bruce this is a
version that actually tried to reason
with the penguin they tried to like work
alongside the penguin and actually
became
a criminal lord himself and then rose to
power and gained more power than the
penguin did and then the tables turned
so that when penguin was basically
losing all of his clout all this power
and all this money he tried to reason
with this version of bruce but was
always pushed out so this version of
bruce wayne is basically a mob boss
and it's kind of cool to see like he's
dark he's sinister and it's interesting
to see that happen because of course the
batman who laughs
kills that version of bruce and then
tells tells penguin if what you're
looking for
is the person who basically set all this
in motion a person who seems to be like
skewing your dice to where it's taking
away the effect of like the house
rigging the games and so on and so forth
then go talk to one of your guys named
matches malone now for those of you guys
who don't know
matches malone is the criminal
underworld identity of bruce wayne
he uses the name matches malone to
infiltrate the criminal underworld so no
one really knows that he's actually
bruce wayne it's a long-standing secret
identity it's one of those little easter
eggs and hallmarks that fans love seeing
brought up all over the place but it's a
cool little thing here because what
batman who laughs does is basically
send penguin on the trail of matches
malone now that probably won't come to
fruition for quite some time but what it
does mean is that somewhere later on
around the corner presumably when scott
snyder starts writing into other batman
stories and so on the penguin will start
looking for matches malone
all the while totally unaware of the
fact that he's basically tracking down
batman
and just not knowing it so it's kind of
cool here because what ends up happening
is that when batman basically gets james
gordon jr back to the waterways and says
hey look i need you to look at
everything here and use your
psychopathic
intelligent mind to figure out what's
the best way to spread some toxin around
gotham and like destroy the entire city
james gordon jr initially begins to kind
of bend and say okay
but then he asks a question he says like
tell me one thing did joker get to you
did the joker get you and joker infect
you because if he did
that's the key to the plan there's no
there's nothing i can really do here if
anything i'm like a stopgap measure you
know i can't really do a whole lot of
things here like there's not a whole lot
that i can that i can offer in this
scenario i mean he does what he can but
like that's really it but in the middle
of it all suddenly like alfred pops up
the bat cave has basically been trashed
the joker's literally like he's got his
heart
like his chest is open he's got his
heart sitting there he's been riding
hahaha in blood
all over the place like it's absolutely
bonkers and so so what ends up happening
is like when the question is asked by
james gordon jr what do we do next
batman says we do the only thing we can
do the one thing that we should have
been doing the entire time the one thing
the joker told me to do at the beginning
of all this the one thing everybody's
been telling me all this time
the one thing that i was supposed to do
this whole time and never really wanted
to do in the first place and so what
ends up happening here is that when
alfred finally makes his way back to the
bat cave
and then finding out that he cannot
access the the proper location
and then has to go to like one of the
exterior entrances when he gets down
there we end up finding out that what
batman's done
it's removed all the toxin uh all the
toxin blocks from his body
and totally given in to like the joker's
serum this is the only plan that i have
i have to become the batman who laughs i
have to become this version of the
character in order to be able to defeat
him
crazy with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you